Curtin's ill who's a chemist we'll be
telling you about his expertise which is
in magnetic resonance and he's one of
the world experts so we're very
fortunate to have him here we're also
fortunate to have him because actually
he's on leave from Yale but he's decided
that he wanted to do this because he's
very passionate about getting students
excited about science so let's welcome
him and thank him as he comes to the
podium
I guess I am off thanks Anissa and thank
you all for coming out this early on a
on a Saturday morning so this is right
I'm a what's called a nuclear magnetic
resonance spectroscopy that's a it's a
big mouthful this is some artwork from
my laboratory that just shows the sorts
of things that we that we do and what I
want to do today is try to explain to
you how nuclear magnetic resonance works
and give you examples of actually where
you encounter this quite often in your
everyday lives so we're going to talk
about investigating samples that might
be liquid chemicals solid materials
small animals or maybe even yourself if
you're getting an MRI and you get put in
an antenna that we're going to call a
probe coil that picks up signals that
your body produces when you're put in a
really big magnet so we got to talk
about magnets um those signals get
analyzed by what's essentially a very
fancy radio receiver and a computer and
we put out things called spectra or
images and so today I'm going to try to
go over all the different pieces why is
it that your body is full of magnets and
how can you actually get radio waves
emanating out and can we detect those
and what can we learn about the about
materials and that's our fashion so
we're going to talk about magnetic
dipoles and electromagnets I'm going to
talk about how magnets align you all
know how a compass lines up with the
Earth's magnetic field we're going to do
some demonstrations of that and
something called torque the when you
twist an axle and you make a wheel turn
that's putting a torque on we're going
to show how how a magnet can produce a
torque on another magnet and that allows
us to do something called larmor
precession and detect a signal through
something called Faraday induction then
we'll talk a little bit about
superconductors because this is the way
we get really big magnets and we'll talk
about spectral analysis and we won't do
this with NMR signals but we'll we'll do
this with well with volunteers from the
audience probably and then we'll talk a
little bit about it I'm our imaging and
applications and all sorts of different
life from Iraq to oil well drilling to
chemistry so magnets and magnetic
dipoles right so we all know that a
compass needle
will orient in the Earth's magnetic
field and magnets basically attract one
another right so we a magnet will have a
North Pole and a South Pole the opposite
poles will attract let's get the lights
off here and we have we usually describe
Magnus by their lines of force um if I
take let's see so what I have here is an
array of compass Meg's these are all
little individual magnets and I've got a
great big magnet here how big is this is
this magnet this magnet is pretty big
you can stick your tools together with
these magnets and not have any it's a
very handy sort of tool chest to have
right you don't want to get too close to
your credit cards though it it'll take
care of those in short order get these
off now I can look at the lines of force
of this big magnet when I put it on top
of the little magnets they all line up
in that fashion right so you can see you
know as we have here the lines of force
in this diagram I showed the lines the
magnets lining up straight here coming
out the ends of the late they curve
around and for those science geeks it's
kind of fun to just play around and see
the magnets move all right the endless
endless endless amusement I know and
this so would like to play with this a
little bit more so now there are other
sorts of ways that we can see magnetic
fields and one of the more fascinating
ones as I've shown you we can always you
know pick up tools to serve a fashion so
a magnet will take something that's
magnetizable right and turn it into a
magnet milla track and you can pick one
up with the other one of the coolest
materials around is something called a
ferrofluid
so it's like the black oil from the
x-files alright right and it you know it
just sort of moves around here and this
this too until I get a magnet close to
it all right
and you see it go in the lines of force
right and I can sit here and Oh sort of
move it back and forth again this is
this is endless hours of fun playing
with us right and fact there are artists
that use this to make kinematic
sculptures and so basically what's
happening is the the magnetic particles
is your little tiny iron nanoparticles
that are in an organic matrix and then
there's a suspended here in a in a
organic fluid that's clear right and
they're showing the lines of force that
that we have on the Meg so magnets have
lines of force and they attract other
magnets okay right now the magnets that
I've just shown you are our permanent
magnets right we can also make magnets
by taking a current and running it
through wires so if we we have a loop of
wire and we run a current through it and
many of you have probably done this
before put it around an iron nail to
make an electromagnet when you run the
current through that you'll you'll get
an electromagnet and that electromagnet
is just like these permanent bar magnets
this just shows a couple of pairs of
loops and the lines of force and I have
a big one here that that I can
demonstrate and if I run current through
this particular electromagnet I can make
it all right now this billiard ball that
I have here we're going to play with
this a lot this is a is also is a magnet
I can get it here yep it's also as the
Megan thinks they stick together and
it's going to orient in this magnetic
field actually maybe I can take the big
one to stick it in here right so if I
have no current the magnetic field can
you see that in the back you see that it
didn't jump up like that all right as I
turn the current over to knock it over
but if I turn the current up right it'll
jump up in that sort of a fashion so for
those of you that couldn't see that I
can probably go to the next
and we'll just look at that in the video
so here again I have this billiard ball
on an air bearing so we've got air
blowing up underneath this and what I've
just done there is turned the current on
all right if it's working well right so
I turn it up alright and it'll sit there
and it'll it'll Bob back and forth if I
turn the current off it falls over right
like that turn it on it'll Bob back up
like so so the magnetic field from the
electromagnets is making the little
magnet orient right so I just let it sit
there turn the magnetic field off it'll
just fall over because the weight of
gravity is going to make it fall over
because it's got that little knob on the
top right so I can make a one magnet
Orient and the magnetic field of another
and electromagnets are convenient ways
of doing that now why do we care
well it's because you're full of magnets
and to explain that we first have to
talk about matter so the things we want
to investigate are all made of matter
and matter is made of molecules right so
matter is made of molecules molecules
are made of atoms so these are the
components of air and many of the
components of air looking for I've got
too many toys out here I can lose my
laser pointer like being at Toys R Us
for a scientist right don't know which
one to play with first so nitrogen is in
error and it's dying nitrogen molecules
it's got two atoms of nitrogen oxygens
in air
two atoms of oxygen co2 the greenhouse
gas you all hear about it's got an atom
of carbon and two atoms of oxygen in
this sort of arrangement bigger
molecules we represent them as how we
stick the atoms together you know sort
of like connects right and so here we
have ethanol in green I've showed two
carbon atoms the white ones are the
hydrogen atoms there's an oxygen and
there's a Hydra so that's the structure
of that molecules we stick those atoms
together and bigger molecules will they
have many many many more atoms so
molecules are arrangements of different
types of atoms now the atoms themselves
have a structure right and the atoms are
consist of electrons so those are the
negative charges that are the currents
carriers of electricity right and
negative charges will be attacked by
positive charges
the nucleus of every atom is a positive
charge and different elements have
different sizes of positive charge
different numbers of electrons they
balance one another out right so the
simplest element hydrogen rings that we
hear a lot about is that the molecular
hydrant to burn is a fuel that atom has
got a single positive charge in the
nucleus called a proton with an electron
going around it
carbon atoms right have actually six
protons and six electrons right so that
makes them different they also happen to
have six neutrons that don't have any
charge but it makes the atom heavier
right and I can have different isotopes
deuterium is another kind of hydrogen
it's called heavy hydrogen you probably
heard of that in books about nuclear
reactors and that has an extra Neutron
in the nucleus that makes it different
than hydrogen the molecules stick
together when the when the atoms share
electrons and that lets them bind to one
another now why do we care well
different nuclei have different
structures and in molecules they have
different arrangements of electrons and
it turns up the nuclei themselves are
magnetic right there are many nuclei are
magnetic and they act just like this
little bar magnet and they'll align that
a magnetic field so all of your mostly
water and your and water has got lots of
hydrogen atoms right and so all those
protons will just align in a magnetic
field packed in the Earth's magnetic
field right well it was well show your
your protons are all processing right
now all right all right so they line up
in a field and there's lots of different
nuclei protons carbon 13 is an isotope
of carbon at 1% natural abundance
nitrogen 15 and Fox was 31 at
all-important nuclei for magnetic
resonance now to explain how we do
magnetic resonance I have to explain to
you not only why nuclei have a magnetic
moment but they also have something
called angular momentum and angular
momentum is a key property that allows
us to detect the fact that the nuclei
your body spin in a magnetic field and
so you've all seen a figure skater
spinning around and when they move their
arms in they'll spin faster that's due
to the conservation of angular momentum
now I need a volunteer
you know volunteer
see here let's see here let's see here
all will go with the one on the front
here come on come on down we'll do it
we'll do a couple okay you can come take
a look too okay now this is a big
gyroscope right the beginning to go
right and I let it go it's going to spin
now what just sit down the stool here
all right what I sit on down
what's your name Carson how you doing
today Carson okay now I want you to
stick your hands out I'm buddy I'm gonna
hand this to you right and hold it out
away from yourself all right
now try to twist it Coop's okay stick
your feet up get your foot off it yet so
you can do it again
now stick your now twist okay
turn it back the other way yeah keep
your feet off the ground
I gotta get picked balls here the
shorter legs let's try this again
so put your put your put your put your
feet on the up up here I'm just gonna
try this again let me get this going
faster
okay now twist it twist 90 degrees just
twist at 90 degrees there you go all
right so this is the conservation of the
angular momentum it that the the angular
momentum wants to be conserved and when
you twist this over it imparts it to
yourself instead you turn it the other
way you'll go in the opposite direction
there you go okay
of course now if it stops if you twist
it it doesn't do anything and I won't
and it won't turn over and everyone
afterwards can try it well let everybody
come down afterwards we have plenty of
time we have lots of demonstrations
thank you very much Carson now it's
another demonstration of this just to
let you see that this will not tip over
there's a restoring force you know
gravity wants to make this tip over if I
stick it on its side so I get this going
I can stick it on the stand here all
right it doesn't fall over all right and
the angular momentum is transferred to
the stand if I don't grab it pretty soon
it's gonna fall off right of course what
it does stop you know there's nothing
nothing holding it gravity will pull it
over right so we're gonna see that the
fact that nuclei also have angular
momentum is key right so if I have a
nuclear moment right
it has charged and it spins spinning
charge makes a magnet just like an
electromagnet right so I have both
angular momentum and a nuclear magnet
and if I put that in a magnetic field
it's going to process now will come down
and let you look at this little device
that I have here afterwards if I if I
were to take this the magnet then you
probably won't be able to see this if I
do it here but we see if it's just
sitting here it turns over but if I can
spin this by hand I can't do it very
well if I were to take my drill here and
spin it by hand what you'll see is that
the top just spins and it won't come
back up because of the magnetic field
now if I turn the magnetic field on what
happens is this
to rotate around now here I've turned
the magnetic field on about halfway
right and that determines the rate at
which is turning around if I cranked the
current up twice as far make the
magnetic field bigger then the top
starts to spin faster so I have a magnet
with angular momentum in a magnetic
field it'll spin around if I stop turn
the current off it stops if I turn the
currently in opposite direction make the
magnet point in the other direction then
the magnet will process in the opposite
direction so when you are put into an
MRI machine as well as we'll talk about
your protons are all processing about
that magnetic field right now what what
uses that well the use of that is that
we can detect that signal by looking at
the radio waves that you can detect
through a process known as magnetic
induction right now this is a device
that we used to demonstrate this I've
got a little ammeter to the side and
this detects when a current flows
through one of these coils Faraday's law
of induction says if I take a magnet and
move it in a coil I'll induce a current
and I'll see an electro-motive force so
if I take for instance my ferrofluid
here right it doesn't do anything
because it's not permanently magnetized
but if I take this large magnet I
deflect the needle so if I have a moving
magnet moves back and forth I'll make an
oscillating current you're off actually
somewhat familiar with this and that if
you go up there there's a tonic river
and look at a power plant that's using a
hydroelectric power basically the water
is flowing to turn a turbine and the
turbine has got some it got some
permanent magnets stuck to the end of it
and there's a coil of wire around that
and those moving magnets then induce an
electric current into the power lines
that feed their homes the reverse sort
of process works in
motor where you put a current in to a
coil that makes loss letting feel that
takes the permanent magnets on the shaft
and turns those around as well so seeing
this process you know used in everyday
life you know all the time and once we
have electric cars that's you know
that's how we'll sit we'll see this all
the time that nuclear induction right
works in the same sort of way I have a
coil it's going to be my sensor coil and
my nuclear moment is going to be the
thing that's rotating right in a nuclear
moment when it rotates then we'll induce
a signal in in the magnet all right now
let's let's talk about how we induce
these sorts of signals and how we we
think about them now it's hard to
demonstrate the nuclear magnetic
resonance experiment here and a
demonstration that you can see I mean
the nuclear moments are very tiny but we
can look at how a microphone works and
that's a very similar sort of a process
so a microphone it has a diaphragm
attached to a coil and when you speak
you make sound waves that go they go out
and they'll vibrate that diaphragm and
move the coil next to a permanent magnet
well that's going to induce a signal
here right and we're going to be able to
record those so I'm going to get this
little software program in my PC here
that lets me turn it into an
oscilloscope alright and now I need
another volunteer someone who can
whistle whistle all right right over
here on the audio yep yep come on up
Thompson alright so in here we go
alright come on up alright so we say
science Saturday's right so can you
whistle yep so you see we're picking up
the whistle with the microphone on the
side of this of the of the computer
whistle again okay so that's that's a
good one alright so now what we're going
to do is we'll we'll capture that if we
will go and now look at what happens
when we analyze this by doing something
called a Fourier transform now the
oscillating signal that we saw saw from
the microphone goes into the computer
and we plan
operation called a Fourier transform
what that does is it takes that single
tone that single oscillation period out
of the signal and produces a graph where
I plot the frequency that's how many
times per second we go from up two down
two up two down that's the frequency of
the signal and it's amplitude so this is
the Fourier transform so we can run the
program again and actually actually look
at the Fourier transform of your whistle
right we're so we're gonna see what sort
of a spectrum that is so we're gonna put
it in frequency mode here instead all
right now go ahead and whistle as loud
as you can let's see if we can see it
here now I don't have the right
frequencies okay go ahead and whistle
okay go a lot of that whoops it's not
armed let's turn it on now try okay so
let's let's see if we can just pick pick
one of those all right so whistle what's
the loud again oh no okay let's see here
if we can do this of course it's not
there we go alright so here I have the
spectrum of the time domain signals if I
can get this to be just a whistle again
alright so here we have a whistle don't
you have a seat
right so this is my single tone from
that whistle you notice that this
spectrum is very different than when we
were just talking and making noise in
the eyes we had lots of Peaks coming up
a whistle has a single peak and if I
look at the frequency of this I can
measure that by clicking on it and it
says the frequency here is about 1840
Hertz if I look in the time domain
alright of that signal and this is the
graph now that shows how this is going
back and forth I'll spread it out in
time and now I can come in and measure
the period how often the signal repeats
itself right and that's the frequency
and again it's about 1800 Hertz right so
this time-dependent signal right when we
and analyze it
gives us a spectrum right and so we can
look at for instance if I can go back to
the frequency domain and I say hello
whoops let's go back again farming
science no no not loud enough right now
science Saturday's
alright so here I have many Peaks that
pop up in the spectrum and if I look at
the time domain signal alright I'll see
that I have a whole bunch of different
frequencies that are in there alright so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take nuclear induction signals that have
lots of lots of Wiggles in them and
analyze them in terms of their spectrum
and each one that's going around at its
own rate will give a different peak in
the spectrum okay now all right
now I could do this sort of show you how
I could do this with a rotating magnet
right so all the lights on so I can't
show you a spin but I can turn one of my
magnets into a spin alright so I'll take
one of my strong neodymium-iron-boron
magnets I'm going to turn it into a spin
that I can spin like this alright and
then the receiver coil that I have right
it's a bunch of coils of wire right and
I can now plug this into the PC and
place up my microphone now if I go back
and turn the turn the PC into an
oscilloscope again alright and now look
at the time domain signals that we're
going to get out of this all right yeah
this is working all right so if I you
know move
the laser pointer by does it does does
absolutely nothing but if I get the okay
the frequency range is very hard to get
this frequency to be high enough because
I can't spin this that fast but now if I
take my nuclear moment and I bring this
by right I start to link the lines of
force I can now make a nuclear induction
signal
alright so that nuclear induction signal
this it gets pointy it's going to hurt
my computer
alright this nuclear induction signal
doubt comes from the moving magnet the
magnets not moving you know so it goes
back and forth that's because I turn the
magnet one way and then the other way it
in one way in the other way so I can
induce a signal into a coil and that's
going to be the basis of the nuclear
magnetic resonance experiment now a
couple of guys Ed Purcell and Felix
Bloch back in the 50s invented this
technique and they got the Nobel Prize
for it the reason they got the Nobel
Prize and what why did they invent this
well they invented this technique
because the frequency that a given
element will newt eight about a magnetic
field depends on its gyromagnetic ratio
that's just a fancy name for what's that
proportionality and that tells you
something about the structure of the
nucleus how the protons and neutrons are
put together right that's something that
you usually have to do in a huge
facility an accelerator facility this
was tabletop physics and this was great
that you could do this alright so these
guys got the Nobel Prize basically for
figuring out how to major the
gyromagnetic ratio in tabletop physics
and learn a lot about nuclear structure
now unfortunately for the physicists as
they try it and they always do this
physicists try to make your things
precisely then more precisely and more
precisely more precisely man making a
better magnetic field that was more
uniform across the sample you see if
this field is different it went into the
sample than the other then one end of
the sample gives a different frequency
than the other end doesn't right that
was a problem they had broad line and as
they made it narrower and narrower what
they found is that you put it in a
molecule like ethanol that you got more
than one line the Jeremie netic ratio
was different depending on the sample so
that was that was bad news for physics
right they they didn't like that they
called it the chemicals
shift that was the most derogatory term
that could come up with I mean you know
Kenneth's you know did this sort of
thing but this was just great for
chemistry
it's a serendipitous discovery and
magnetic resonance just permeates
chemistry now and you know this is an
example of sort of the difference
between what you which you might call
hypothesis-driven research say you're
interested in photosynthesis and you
have some idea of how it works design an
experiment you test it out to see what
happened first us what might be caused
the engineering model of research where
you get a new capability so you can
discover things you know sort of like
building the Golden Gate Bridge
there was an idea yeah you could get
from one side to the other but all the
other stuff that came about because they
built that no one would have believed
the development and into the traffic it
would have had until it was built the
integrated circuits the same sort of
thing well they could make circuitry
more efficient but the notion that we
had actually would have personal
computers much less Wiis you know or
Xboxes you know was just totally whoops
there's a reminder yep I think I'm here
you know we we just couldn't have
imagined that so there's a lot of
important scientific advances that come
about because of serendipity this was an
example that discovered the chemical
shift right and being able to use us to
analyze matter as an example of a
serendipitous discovery all right so
let's see what we've talked about so far
we talked about how if we take a sample
it has magnetic moments anything in the
around us has got magnetic moments we
put it in a coil they're going to move
and we put them in a magnetic field
right and then we'll get a big signal
out and we'll take that signal and
analyze the frequencies and we'll be
able to learn about the structure of
matter so I said we need big magnets now
why do we need big Magnus well big
magnets make the signals bigger we want
bigger magnets to do that it makes it a
lot easier to detect the signals and
this sort of a fashion
and so we make bigger and bigger and
bigger magnets now the Earth's field
would give a proton or frequency about
the frequency of that whistle about 1700
cycles per second or Hertz right when
you get in an MRI it's a frequency more
like 64 megahertz that's like the
frequencies on your FM radio about right
we have an instrument here at Yale that
allows us to do NMR at 800 megahertz
that's up for TV signals happen to be
right now how do we make these great big
magnets well we do this through the use
of what are called superconductors when
you put current through these coils if
you came up here afterwards you felt the
coils with the current that I'm putting
through me it gets hot the coils can
only carry so much current because they
have a finite resistance to the flow of
electricity to make the biggest magnets
around we would end up melting the
windings so we use something called a
superconductor that has no resistance we
can put as much current as we want
through it probably's we have to get the
superconductors very very low now I
can't demonstrate how a superconductor
loses it's it's it's it's resistance
that easily but I can I can show how a
superconducting transition takes place
when I when I pour some liquid nitrogen
on a superconductor so I want to show
you an example of magnetic levitation
using what's known as a high-temperature
superconductor and let's see if we can
put this up on the screen so try to put
the demonstration there we go
so what I have here next to to and we
have to have to thank gamma my my wife
sitting right here could you raise your
hand please thank you for letting me use
her video camera well I'm cooling this
done I'm curious now now many of you
heard about this on the radio but how
many of you are here because you went to
school is one of my six kids no one's
going to admit it yeah there's a yeah
okay there's a few all right so what I
have here is a little rare earth magnets
all right those are these are these
little tiny magnets and I have a sample
of if tree and barium copper oxide
superconductor it's just a just a disk
it's not magnetic you know this doesn't
it doesn't attract whatsoever right and
this becomes a superconductor somewhere
around the temperature of liquid
nitrogen and so if I pour the liquid
nitrogen on this and try to cool it this
down as I cool it down this is going to
go superconducting and what will happen
is that the magnetic lines of force will
be excluded from the superconductor and
we're going to see the magnet levitate
right so it's getting close
around here we're gonna go boiling away
closer and being to ginger with it but I
want to try to avoid doing is pointless
there we go alright so now it's they're
sitting there it's levitating above the
superconductor right and I can sit here
and it'll just sit there and I'll just
spin in the air alright as it love it
takes all right so it's just it's just
sort of you know this is this is not
exactly how they did that scene in The
Exorcist with the bed right but it's the
same sort of thing right and if we sit
here wait for the liquid nitrogen to
cool off we'll see that the the magnet
will just fall back down onto onto onto
the superconductor now how cold is this
liquid nitrogen I mean it's pretty cold
yet again I've lost my laser pointer
here it is right so the temperature
scale you're familiar with is the
Fahrenheit one right where water boils
at 212 if you look at your temperature
gauge and your auto you see it's two
hundred and some-odd degrees you're in
trouble with your radiator right we know
it freezes at 32 degrees and ran a warm
day at somewhere up here around seventy
and a really cold and kinetic is down
here around zero all right liquid
nitrogen is down here minus 321 degrees
right so this stuff is awfully cold you
don't want to get this on your feet
right it's sitting here and it just it
just boils you know it disappears right
as it tries to cool down the terrazzo
which it really can't do like oh I don't
have any left here I'll have to get some
more right more afterwards right and we
actually in making these strong magnets
use liquid helium alright so the gas it
goes in balloons that's at minus four
hundred and fifty three degrees
Fahrenheit you can't get any colder than
minus 459 that's what we call absolute
zero on the Kelvin scale right this is a
cross-section of a superconducting
magnet let me put that on the center
screen so if we if we look at the cross
section of this superconducting magnet
whoops
what a venire
we have a big coil alright and we have a
bunch of Dewar's vacuum vessels
essentially thermos bottles around this
that we're trying to keep the liquid
helium in right I'll turn this around to
the side so here's my superconducting
coil and I have a big vessel here that I
have to fill with liquid helium to keep
it it 4 degrees Kelvin with the niobium
titanium wires that are in there to make
them superconducting and because that's
going to boil off really fast even if I
have a vacuum space around just the heat
radiating through that is going to make
that boil off what we do is we put
another vacuum vessel around it and then
another can that I feel with liquid
nitrogen because liquid nitrogen is
cheap okay so we we're always filling
these devices with liquid helium and
liquid nitrogen when you go get in an
MRI machine you're in a bigger version
of this and that surrounding on the
outside has got a big vessel of liquid
helium and a big vessel of liquid
nitrogen around it and that's why the
technician leaves well if you're in the
room okay now with these really big
magnetic fields all right we stick
different molecules in we get different
spectra and this is sort of a chemist
version of Sudoku puzzles right looking
at NMR spectra right Katie can you do
these you learn about these yes you
learned about these in when you take
organic chemistry you know you learn how
to do so these are different molecular
formulas or stoichiometric formulas
right for different molecules and it
gives me different spectra so how can I
understand how these different lines
right these are the different rates at
which the different protons are spinning
around there are eight protons and this
molecule and 14 in this one but they
spin around the magnetic field how can I
understand what the structure is of the
basis of their NMR spectrum that's
actually it's not too hard to understand
so what are the what are the the origins
so the nuclear spin doesn't see just the
field the superconducting magnet but it
sees the field that the molecule puts on
it
there's electrons in there and the
electrons move around now if if I'm in
an atom the electrons are bounced off
the nucleus and and this is where I
would see the the NMR spectrum of an of
an atom but when I when I have electrons
in the atom it turns out the electrons
when they move in a magnetic field they
curve that's how your old TV set works
it's got an electron beam that goes out
and hits the phosphor and there's a
magnet that moves that beam and we're
Astor's it back and forth and so because
the electrons moving
they make a magnetic field it's
proportional to the size of the applied
magnetic field that's called the
shielding so the line moves depending on
how many ions are around so different
parts of the molecule using different
amounts of this chemical shielding the
physicists called it now there are other
nuclei in the molecule so it's not just
there's a single proton there's other
protons nearby and they're little mint
and those little magnets see each
other's skills so I see a field from one
magnet do to do to the other so it sees
a shift because of that little dipolar
field and it turns out because of a
quant what's called a quantum mechanical
effect these nuclei only arrange
themselves in the magnet in two ways we
can see the face of the lineup it turns
out that they can also be lined up side
down perfectly they have those two
possible orientations and so that means
that not only do I see a field from the
magnet in this direction I'll see a
field from the magnet that directions so
instead of one line I get two because he
sees a neighbor and the size of that
tells me something about the distance
between the nuclei now the spectra I
just showed you we have another kind of
coupling color we call it J coupling
because we like to make up names for
things right and it's the same as that
dipolar feel except they have to do with
the fact that the electrons themselves
have magnetic moments and if the two
nuclei have a chemical bond between them
then I'll see field transmitted through
the electron and it will depend on this
whether the nucleus is up or down and so
I'll get a splitting that tells me but
those two nuclei have a bond so this is
really perfect for chemists if you think
of chemistry's being a lego set right
and you have you know round round Legos
and square Legos the square ones are the
bonds and the rounds of the atoms and
you stick them together and you want to
know know which types which colors do I
have how are they put together whose
neighboring who so the patterns tell me
you know there's one new one for each
distinct atomic Center so that's a stoic
geometry the ratios of the elements and
their different types the couplings tell
me how they're connected and the number
of lines tells me something about
chemical equivalency so let's do this
Sudoku puzzle and figure out what the
structure of this molecule happens to be
so it's got four carbons eight
hydrogen's and two oxygens right and
I've got three groups of signal this
tells me I've got three types of
hydrogen atoms
and they come in a ratio of two to three
to three because of I add up the heights
of these I get it a height of two a
height of three and I stick that one on
top of that and this on top of that it
ends up being three also right that
tells me because I know some of the
rules of organic chemistry that I must
have two of the hydrogen's on one carbon
and the other ones come in groups of
three that's called a methyl group we
have an F so I've got three on it on a
carbon right I also know because of
their positions right that this one
that's the the ch2 has got to be next to
an oxygen and then I can tell from the
patterns how many neighbors they've got
now does that work well this guy's a
single line right he has no neighbors he
doesn't see anybody so he must be a
methyl that's got a bond off to
something I don't know quite what yet
but he's off by himself this guy well
he's got three lines and it means he's
got two neighbors how do I know that
well if I have two neighbors they can
both be up they could both be down all
right gonna have one up or one down and
there's two ways of doing that right so
I get a lines one two two two one oh
this guy's got three neighbors right
because I've got four lines again three
up three down two down one up one down
two up alright so I have those sorts of
patterns so these guys are neighboring
so oh that CH trees got to be next to
that CH ER they've got to be stuck
together that way right right and then
if I by process of elimination I have a
carbon left over and an oxygen the only
way I can stick them together and make
sure there are four things stuck on
every carbon is to make this molecule
ethyl acetate so that's the spectrum of
ethyl acetate if I taken and you know
made a me that made it different made
this an alcohol instead move this this
oxygen somewhere else I get a totally
different spectrum right so this is so
important to chemistry that there's
another nobel prize for NMR this guy
Richard Hertz the fee at the 8a ha start
off as an electrical engineer became a
chemist right and he got the Nobel Prize
for the way that we do in a Mara
spectroscopy these days
now just across Long Island Sound
another guy unfortunately passed away
last week invented a technique known as
NMR is IMET ography the guy was a
terrible PR person no one was going to
remember zeig matagi that sounds like a
bad disease he invented NMR imaging this
is Paul Lauterbur and he was over at
Stony Brook
and he had this idea that we all thought
was crazy at the time says you know we
always try to get a perfect magnetic
field so the samples always have the
same field and every nucleus at the same
type has the same tone it makes the tone
sharp and we don't know if you put a bad
field on one that varied a lot across a
sample the tongue would just sound
terrible and the spectrum would be broad
it would have no information pause it's
not if you if you made the field very
linearly you might be able to make an
image and this is kind of nutty but this
was the idea so I made a plot here of
magnetic field strength versus distance
all right I've got three test tubes of
water of different sizes and shapes if I
put that in the NMR machine and I had
this kind of a field the spectrum would
look like this the field at position a
is da and I'd get this frequency Omega a
and at B it's going to be different
right it's gonna be a higher field I'll
get a higher frequency right and there's
a range of frequencies because the tube
is battered right and so I would get
this the spectrum would be the image of
the set of what we call phantoms so that
was kind of cute but it seemed totally
impractical right until a guy named
Peter Maass field came along and he came
up with some really clever ideas of
making time-dependent gradients and
doing all sorts of fancy stuff and he
showed data that came out of a lemon and
gave us his first image we thought wow
that's really cool and I was just
starting graduate school at this time I
could have got into it and thought
that's never gonna go anywhere you know
within two years
General Electric totally commercialize
us and we're now seeing brain scans you
know so you this looks at all the soft
tissue on your body and the way MRI
works right is that it's basically
looking at the protons of the water
because you're mostly made of water and
of course it became a medical technique
so the nuclear was dropped because
everybody was afraid of a nuclear test
and so you know so it's just MRI now
instead of n MRI and man's man's feeling
blood where they got the Nobel Prize in
2003 so a third Nobel Prize here for NMR
right for discovering magnetic resonance
imaging now how many of you have had an
MRI tell me you're lying
you've had many MRIs how many have had
an MRI with contrast with caucus so some
of you have been injected with
gadolinium compounds right so so it
turns out that
that when you do an MRI image if you put
magnetic particles right in the subject
those magnetic particles will affect the
signal right and by affecting the signal
you can broaden the lines and so if I
look at the image different parts of the
sample of different languages so I can
see where the contrast agent is that's
sort of a cool thing right and so they
they bind the water loosely and that
effects there and a mark and there's
another technique called bold imaging it
turns out this is blood oxygen level
dependent contrast turns out that oxygen
molecules have what we call unpaired
electrons that also makes them magnetic
and so wherever there's oxygen molecules
that affects the line which is the same
way as the contrast agents now when you
think your metabolism either uses up
oxygen or gives off oxygen into the
blood right so the oxygen levels will
move around in your head as you think
and so we can use us to detect things
like this so here are some brain images
of two groups of patients right and
they're being spoken to right right you
notice this group here they're using
both words living lighting up that's
where I have this bold contrast and
they're using both sides of their brain
right when they're listening to speech
this other group is defective in some
way right they're only using one side of
their brain to speak anybody got a clue
as to what's wrong with group a they're
men yes these are men
these are women
all the women are laughing yeah the guys
are going yeah yeah yeah our wives
didn't need to know this right right I
prefer to think that what we're we're
only being told things that are you know
worth using half our brains to listen to
but you know that doesn't my take on it
right okay so there there are all sorts
of things we can do we can do with with
MRI imaging and it's just amazing that
the sorts of experiments one can do
because of this now another thing that
you could do with NMR is you can
determine the structures of really big
molecules and that's something that's
akin to the research that I do proteins
are molecules that really make us work I
mean if we didn't have proteins you know
we just we just we just wouldn't work
all sorts of things in our metabolism we
think the way we move everything comes
down to a protein so what's a protein
right so a protein is a is a series of
amino acids stuck together in a polymer
amino acids are these molecules so this
let's just look at this one of the
corner here this is alanine right so
every every amino acids got this motif
with a nitrogen the carbon the carbon
the oxygen atoms and then in blue
there's a thing we call the sidechain in
this case it's a carbon with three
hydrogen's called a methyl group right
and different amino acids differ by
these side chains and we string them
together and that makes a protein so
this list of letters here are the single
letter abbreviations right for all of
these different amino acids and this
protein chain that happens to be the
molecule known as ubiquitous right we
might represent it in three-dimensional
structure by showing the list of amino
acids in syrup as I showed you all the
atoms you really wouldn't be able to
comprehend what's going on now I got to
tell you a cute story we're when you're
if you go back up Prospect Street on
your way out there's a new chemistry
building somewhere around 250 Prospect
Street almost at the corner of efforts
and there's this beautiful wrought iron
gate right and on that wrought iron gate
we have some peptides made that happened
to have these different amino acids and
we have a peptide that is made up of
where's tyrosine I'm looking tired
tyrosine we're
my tyrosine right there tyrosine which
is why alanine a leucine L & my glutamic
acid eat yeah so we have this molecule
building says Yale on the game right and
next up we have one that says cysteine
right and then it has a histidine right
glutamic acid again and the thiamine
where is my finding I'm fine Yale Kemp's
it says Yale came across the gate right
now the artist that made these peptides
when he brought the models over for us
to look at his artistic rendition of
them they were made out of these bonds
stick models and that the tyrosine so
the tyrosine yes the tyrosine yeah
they're the the Oh H that was stuck to
the side fell off right and he's showing
us the model and we're looking at it and
it's a tyrosine but it's missing a no H
and we thought that's kind of something
is wrong with this right and well
tyrosine without a no H is phenylalanine
which is an F so instead of Y Elliott
said FA le fail Kevin which a lot of the
undergraduates here thought would have
been more appropriate for us to put up
all right so so proteins
you know there's their structure is not
just this chain is how the molecule
folds on itself and we actually use NMR
to make sure those dipolar fields
between the spins right to see what's
next - what right so we can do that
right and I need I need two volunteers
they're going to determine protein
structures here okay over here right
here and in the very back of the center
okay all right so all right so we have
two polypeptide chains here all right
there we're going to stretch out all
right starts with alanine right you come
over here all right and stretch it out
all right stick your head straight so
what we do we're doing an NMR structure
of a protein is we try to determine
what's next - what all right so I have
two sequences here and I'm going to show
how I can make two different structures
right by looking at the constraints
right so I've done an experiment in case
one right with my green polypeptide here
and suppose number one that's my a can
you see the one there I want you to take
number one and now stick it next to
number 20
so find number 20 down the chain and
stick it on number 20 I think 20 right
about there okay so so tape that
together all right now if I take number
two all right and let's take bloomer
fluff take number four here find number
four all right number four right and
I'll stick that next to number 23 if you
can
he's got a curve it around all right and
I have long enough pieces of tape now
this the tapes aren't strong enough okay
and now let's let's take seven or let's
take ten and put it next to 31 all right
so here's number ten
all right let's stick that next to
number 31 and if you go on around all
right let's do the last one 14 next to
36 14 next to 36 here's 36 there's 14
okay that would say with those
constraints that the protein should fold
up in that sort of a fashion all right
so he's formed what we would call a
helix right now let's suppose instead my
experiment and give me a different set
of data and let's look at the bottom
here let's say one is next to 29 let's
put one next to 29 nice right there
okay so let's stick those two together
all right and then the next one here
let's let's go off to the analyst say
put 45 that's my 45 and stick that next
to 20 all right can't go that way looks
like we got to go back around the other
way flip around backwards yep hold this
tight all right now stick those two
together ah and now if you hold this up
this the sheet does something else this
is called the helix this is called the
beta sheet when you have Alzheimer's
disease what is it yeah your protein
instead of forming an alpha helix forms
a beta sheet right and the plaques that
form there are due to the misc folding
of the protein so the structures of
proteins are very very important there
are other diseases
for instance type 2 diabetes comes about
because of a Mis folding of a protein
and so using NMR to determine protein
structures has been very very important
you guys can keep those if you want
right and so from those restraints what
we do in a computer is we
then used the computer to figure out
from those restraints what the backbone
oughta look like and I did this in
ballin stick as I've been showing you or
space-filling you really couldn't tell
but we typically write out the heel of
season to serve a fashion color coded so
we can see that the curve of the
backbone and we take the sheets and we
we bend them into sort of a fashion and
and we got all sorts of pretty pictures
right to come out and these different
protein folds as we call them all right
imply what their structure is and it
tells us how they function we can learn
how molecules bind in so a lot of
pharmaceutical companies will try to
determine the structures of these
molecules to figure out how drugs are
going to bind to them and this led to
another Nobel price right
we Kirk Boott Raqqah does he shared it
with the one we've heard about this
morning jon-fen
who was just across the way right all
right so there's lots of other big
things in NMR and I don't have time to
tell you about them but you're going to
hear about NMR when you learn about
quantum computing and spintronics when
you go to Reagan Airport you'll go
through an nqr machine that looks for
either cocaine or RDX which is an
explosive of your bags in Iraq they're
using nqr machines to find landmines
slumbers and ridgefield actually puts
NMR machines down in a well and they can
tell the difference between clay sand
stone oil which is where I want to drill
and just water right so with that I hope
you've had a magnetic day today and I'd
like to thank you for your attention I'd
be happy to answer any questions
you